today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza and
bronx-born pizza in Bend Oregon gray
block pizza in Los Angeles get that
hitter Wow
and I hope your weekend was good all
right let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
it was me and that is um an artist named
Jameson flood and that's a man not a
natural disaster and he sent in that
song called every night and we're happy
to play that at the beginning they're
welcome to this past weekend I'm excited
to be here
premature Nick our producer is going to
be in studio with us in a second but
first look I'm amped I am still hiked up
I got to go to Aerosmith this past
weekend I got to go to the UFC fights
dude I hadn't been to a fight you know
since I've seen a couple honestly couple
sisters beating up my buddy that would
had a couple milkshakes in his hand
outside of us since an incense and a tea
but uh but I got to go to the UFC fight
just and I'm not trying to brag but just
a crazy weekend and I want to play this
clip right now cuz we're gonna we're
gonna actually call an interview we're
gonna call an interview of the champ
we're gonna call an interview the champ
ha Dustin Poirier here momentarily but I
want to play a clip really quick from a
previous episode when he came in episode
142 Dustin Poirier right here you just
want to win the belt yeah I just want to
win the belt man that's all I want I
just want to be the world champion and
then I'll go back to delivering windows
so is that is that really that goal I
mean is that so that's the thing that's
the you just want to be the best yeah of
course I would I would love to stay in
the sport for a long time and make my
shitload of money but I just want to say
that I did it I want to have the UFC
championship around my waist you know
all these years with my wife
struggling and and taking food out of
the out of the grocery basket because we
couldn't afford it and making ends meet
and and you know sacrificing a lot I
just want to say it was all worth it
because once you become the world
champion you know that's forever yeah
and you know that's that's what I'm
trying to do honestly Dan that's
powerful man it's really really cool
it's so inspirational very powerful it
was just a powerful night to be there it
was just so inspirational you know
Dustin Poirier is a
nobody's taking I don't think a harder
road to get to a title in the UFC and I
don't know a lot about UFC but I think
we can all relate to adversity and we
and I am constantly inspired by
perseverance and I and just this man
just has it he has it and I was
fortunate to be able to be there there
were so many people that got to witness
in and I want to get him on the line
right now
let's call Dustin Poirier the new
155-pound the champ they can never take
it away from him for the rest of his
life they can never take it away let's
call him up right now go looking for the
champ champ here champs here what's up
brother how are you good man how about
you I'm doing good man congratulations
thank you bro thank you so much how you
feeling today well bust it up you know
what uh feeling good yeah oh yeah man
here's a bunch of bumps and bruises when
you fight like that for 25 minutes with
these caliber of guys you got hit in
spots you didn't even know you got hit
in Europe yeah I guess it doesn't really
feel like a massage does it how are you
celebrating man dude I'm not really
doing a whole lot honestly I uh took my
daughter to the zoo today that's about
it really
yeah does she know that uh does she know
that that uh is a champion yeah I do she
knows man and it makes me feel so good
that's awesome yeah like she calls the
belt the belt you know she said that
daddy so every time she walks by she
points with his daddy's belly's so
pretty if she likes it she loves they
feel so good Batman
now do you find yourself recovering or
do you find yourself like thinking about
training like what kind of like what's
going on like in is sort of in your head
a little in that stuff right now like
I'm just kind of seeing what uh pains
gonna stay longer than a few days what
what what's not and uh you know get what
what's not going to go away in a few
days I'll get a checked out by doctor
get some MRIs done but I feel pretty
pretty healthy and then I kind of the
good thing about this fight is I know my
next step for the most of my career I
didn't know the next step after fights
now we know we're gonna fight could be
to unify the bells oh and he suspended
until September I believe so I know I'm
probably not going to fight until
September so that gives me like a little
peace of mind that a fights not gonna
pop up on me I can kind of start
planning accordingly to that timeline
yeah now do you would that happen in
September or do you it could happen
after that do you have a say-so in that
how does that kind of work no I believe
it's meat you know a khabees the
undisputed champ so him in the UFC I
guess are going to figure it out but his
suspension ends I believe in September
so that doesn't mean he can't start a
training camp before then you know he
can be ready to go as soon as the date
of suspension ends so and that's what
I've heard floating around that
September is the date they're gonna plan
the next fight wow wow man um are you
worried about like I know a lot of these
fighters or it seems like I'm learning
anyway that a lot of a lot of the
fighters like as they you know once you
become a champion once you get a belt
that a lot of the media obligations
become more pertinent especially and
more just you have a lot more
obligations to the media around fight
time and that it can drain a lot of
Fighters do you worry about any of that
I don't really like think about it that
much that can worry about it but now
that you're mentioning a bro this last
fight that lead-up to this last fight I
mean I was non-stop interviews non-stop
going to different places on fight week
which I usually don't know that's new to
me every now and then on a fight we got
go to like a radio station here and
there but this time my whole itinerary
was just full of interviews and places
to be it made the week fly by really but
it is a
distraction and a little bit of stress
yeah did um you you said in an interview
Dustin man that just one of the neatest
things I've ever heard and you said 25
minutes to make life fair can you tell
me a little bit about that yeah brother
uh Teddy yeah I was listening to a
podcast when a Teddy Atlas podcast don't
know if you know Teddy Atlas is he's a
legendary boxing trainer been around a
long time was one of the first guys to
train Mike Tyson Oh
under custom motto just a very very
interesting mind in combat sports when I
was two the guy talked like you know you
just very well spoken about about
feelings and things that fighters go
through and stuff but on this podcast he
was talking about no other time in life
or in history that you have an
opportunity to raise your arms up in the
air and because the best in the world
the champion of the world no matter what
it's except in fighting you know and and
that's what I was looking at coming into
this fight is 25 minutes no matter I
said I've lost in the past
what the oddsmakers say people who told
me I'm not good enough oh you know just
every time I've slipped and fell or
every critic out there every opinion out
there I had 25 minutes to mute that out
yeah and and and in my own hands I had
controlled my destiny and I knew I had
it for 25 minutes and I was very
powerful going into that fight just
knowing that and I wanted to leave all
of myself out there give it my all and
whatever was going to happen was going
to happen but I walked into the cage
that night
comfortable knowing that I was prepared
to do everything that I had physically
you know everything possible of myself I
was willing to do it whatever it took to
win that belt and make life fair for 25
minutes man Wow
you mean you hit the ring you were just
you were feeling good that James Brown
hit the scene man it was uh God that was
live man when now when you're backstage
the fight before you guys was Jesus
Christ man were you watching that I was
also there stairs in the locker room
where you warm up there's a big mat you
know to warm up on himself and there's a
TV there streaming the fights live so
you kind of know where you're at you
know I know how was the main event so
the co-main is going I can
right when it ends I know I have about
five or six minutes where they come get
me and say okay you're good you're
walking now so I was kind of keeping an
eye on it but I didn't get to see every
round you know I was warming up and kind
of just glancing at it so I need to go
back and watch it I haven't yet man it
was powerful I mean it was just at that
point yeah we're just like I'm sitting
there in the stands like Jesus I can't
imagine that there's gonna be more
fighting like it was just those guys had
murdered each other dude I mean
interview you how was your first trip to
a fight oh it was scary man I was
swinging my own almost not my date out
one time so that was kind of alarming
how what meant it was uh it gave me a
whole different respect for for uh for
fighters like even just a minute ago
when you said that they come and walk
you from the back out there five minutes
up that to me feels like an electric
chair like they would be walking me like
dead man walking you know like to the
last moment to be honest with you and
you know fighting everybody thinks guys
are tough guys you know I'm a bad dude
for sure I can fight I'm one of the best
in the world and I know like what I'm
capable of but I'm not immune to those
feelings I'm scared to death back there
even though I'm so prepared and and you
know put in so many years and months
into this single training camp like this
one guy well there's still the other
unknown out there I don't
anything could happen I know I'm human
if I make a mistake and get kneed in the
face I know I'll get knocked out right
so you know we're in a weird way as they
come get you and say alright Dustin
you're walking it's almost you feel like
you're being led I don't want to say
it's a slaughter but you're being led to
a crowd full of people and you're about
to step in the in the you know in an
arena and frickin you know it feels like
you're going out there to fight to the
death
that's what it feels like to me Wow does
it um is there uh can you feel the crowd
when you're out there or is are you just
so you guys are just so zoned in to what
you're doing
you know earlier in my career I could uh
everything was muted out it was just how
so much adrenaline pounding that I could
only just react and do what I was doing
but now as I've got so many fights under
my belt I can hear everything then yeah
yeah it's so interesting man it's like
if it's like it's like Christmas but
Santa's like trying to beat the [ __ ] out
of you you know that's what it kind of
was like the vibe that it kind of seemed
from me like if I was a I can only
imagine if I was in your shoes it would
be like so exciting because you're ready
it's there you've been waiting for it
but then you gotta like you know Santa's
not bringing gifts dude he's bringing an
ass-whuppin you know right right [ __ ]
man it is kinda like that you're so
excited you're like anxious to perform
you've been working you want everybody
to see what level you're capable of
fighting at you want to show everything
you're you know yeah I've been working
on but at the same time it's still like
oh my god we're doing this and we're
fighting anything could happen
but that's like when you're when you're
a young fighter you don't think about
those things I think those are things
that come along with time and maturity
in the sport like when I was young I
never thought about that
you know the possibility of getting
kidney to the elbow and split in the
face or knocked out I didn't think about
those things I was just going out there
to fight but as you get older you're
like okay you know you've seen some
things and been some places you like
this a dangerous man right this is
dangerous
now a lot of these guys so you know that
you're gonna have this next fight
against khabib it's not for certain yet
but it's close yeah man you know
nothing's for certain mixed martial arts
nothing surprises me anymore I don't
know but I don't know what's gonna
happen but the the plan is to unify the
both Dana told me that Dana's publicly
said it and you know that's what I think
should happen yeah yeah do you worry
about a lot of those guys from certain
parts of the world you know and I'm not
naming any but like dagestan you know
they use like performance-enhancing
drugs and stuff do you worry about that
kind of thing you know you saw it was
pretty pretty tight man we were Olympic
drug tested year-round by you sada hmm
just as well just this last week in
Atlanta I was tested twice my own urine
test on one blood test and I was only
there for five days
you know they do very strenuous testing
year-round so I think they cleaned up
the sport you know I just I just hope
they uh it's an even playing field you
know that's right oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you want it to be fair yeah they I would
have tested positive for being a
straight [ __ ] and the audience to it I
was so scared for us some people got
hurt I was praying for people I texted
the police at one point like it was
getting uh it was crazy man
it was so crazy man just dude I would
think and there were certain moment
trials like just get to the end of the
round and then you have to [ __ ] do
another round dude I know I know Manik
when I last when the fifth Ron came out
for my fight when I got off the stool I
was [ __ ] excited I was like all right
now I can just do it out you know I
could leave everything out of there I
don't have to conserve I don't have to
worry about anything we got five minutes
left to find out who's the best that was
exciting time you know knowing there's
five minutes left in this battle yeah it
seemed like um I mean you just came out
dude I woke up in the middle of the
night and watch the whole fight last
night on YouTube again and yet it's so
much different watching it in person
it's so much more intense than watching
it on television or on tape that's what
that's what that's that's what I try to
tell people who've never been to a live
event like watching even boxing any
combat sport watching it on TV you can
hear the punches land but you don't get
the impact feeling and you don't feel
the energy when you're in there
especially how close you are man you
were down there commentating the fight
and yeah just feel the the energy and
the force and you can see the aggression
and the sweat and blood flying it's just
a totally different feel watching fights
that close bro long sky suddenly I got
scared again right now yeah it was uh it
was everything man and seeing when you
got that belt mantis how yeah I mean
just paid in full man it just it you
could just see it you could just see it
all right there for you mana that must
have just been what was that like it was
uh you know all these years I imagined
getting the belt put on me and imagine
just touching the belt and being a
champion in the UFC but when it actually
happened it was uh it felt like a dream
it's all better than I can even I
I could ever thought it felt like and it
felt right it didn't so you know it felt
like I earned it it's not like twelve
years of work and and it just really
felt good man
I've never felt anything like that I
just felt really accomplished and just
proud of myself you know hey man what
else well I mean it's your journey you
know and I think those are perfect that
seems to be yeah you felt very
accomplished it felt right and it's
interesting that you say it felt like a
dream because it was a this was a dream
of yours so it's like it would almost
make sense that it felt that way I guess
you know right and a dream at times that
has slipped away from me and I didn't
know if I was gonna you know I just in
the back of my head always like no
matter what happened I'm gonna push
through it and overcome and just have
perseverance through anything but you
know still some some days are tough man
some days on the job are tough I've lost
big big fights in the past and going
back home after losing a big fight it's
like man will I ever really make this a
reality and do it when it go and touch
my skin man I just do like all those
years bro all of you yeah it's so
interesting man I gotta actually got a
message from Michael Bisping the other
night and he said man he did it you know
because I've been messaging him the week
before just asking about the fights and
and no one it seems I was looking at
some information online and it said that
no one has had a longer route from their
first fight to a belt and not Bisping
had 26 fights and I guess for you it was
22 and and he said a couple nice things
just such supportive things that he
could really relate to your journey man
do you feel like the journey is over
where do you find motivation and
inspiration now no no you know what I
have is a piece of the World
Championship I have to unify the Bo it
could be when I could win that beat
could be then I'm on top of the mountain
you know right now I'm on I'm on the
edge I got I got a few more steps to go
once I beat khabib then then I'm on top
of the mountain and then it becomes
about legacy you know what can i what
can I do differently than these other
champions yeah can I do the separate
myself in that category there's levels
to it man there's levels to it for sure
yeah but you're a champion man and
that's uh
they can never take it away from you man
congratulations so much and tell me
about your organization one more time
Dustin that you have there and Lafayette
not a Coconut Creek yep yeah me and my
wife have the good fight foundation it's
the good fight group calm if you want
any info but uh we're just doing things
around Acadiana and southern Louisiana
trying to help out trying to use my
platform in the best way I can to make
people you know better in my community
the better they everything we can do you
know we're not set to one specific goal
we do all types of things but this next
goal we have we're building a playground
for disabled children at an elementary
school and I'm really really excited to
do that that's awesome man we're gonna
go online and make a make a donation
right after this and-and-and yeah man
it'd be great if you and I know you know
I've talked about over the past year
about doing maybe a comedy show and
doing some fundraising efforts together
down there and in south Louisiana and
and if you're still willing to do that
man I'd love to be able to you know for
us to see that see that to fruition Oh
hundred percent down I can start working
on it if you want to man it would be
great I think you can really have a huge
turnout and we can get some some good
stuff going for South Louisiana
yeah I think so too man we could start
local I love it uh the champ due
congratulations brother thank you do man
it was awesome to see you out there in
the crowd row dude I was so excited but
I was gonna [ __ ] it if anybody jumped in
I was jumping in you know you know I I
know you had my back look I was gonna
get knocked the [ __ ] out boy I was ready
to get knocked out I even brought a
pillow in my bag so I was ready man
congratulations champion joy your time
with your family thank you so much the
oh brother good to hear from you are you
too man have a good day yep well Nick
Davis I mean you're a big UFC guy and
this is a little bit of a different
episode because look I mean I learned a
lot about the fight yeah
was just inspiring he was inspiring to
see dust and it was scary man it was all
I don't know what was going on then
there's people drinking there's one got
his yelling rat King the whole time I'm
like dude were you even looking at the
[ __ ] fights bro like you can watch me
on youtube you a little charlatan yeah
it was a great night of fights man I did
Dustin seems so pure like everything he
says like yeah he's not trying to put on
airs at all like he he said what he
wanted to do and he did everything he
could to do it he did it yeah yeah I
think that's the thing that resonated me
a lot it's just that you could feel the
perseverance you could feel you know he
just wants to you know he he just it's
interesting and like you know cuz he's a
guy I think he said he dropped out of
school when he was young like I don't
know I don't know if he and he didn't
didn't finish high school so you would
think at a young age that would probably
make somebody feel kind of uncomfortable
because everybody else you know is
graduated in high school or it's
finished in school you know when it's
just not for you where you have you know
I'm gonna face it he had some learning
disabilities or what he had but he had
it just wasn't his thing you know so
then you have to feel a little bit like
an outsider probably then so to find an
avenue with it with fighting and people
are like dude I mean if you're somebody
that's fighting around town like until
you [ __ ] win the belt here Kyle until
like you get in the UFC you're just kind
of an [ __ ] you know you're like
somebody that the cops are like keeping
their eye on and then you start to but
just just I guess to see how somebody
can take something that can find their
path not only find their path but then
continue on it when it's such a I mean
it's such a limited it's a very lean
Mountain you know it seems like that UFC
stuff what do you think yeah totally
especially like he mentioned he a couple
times he got really close to title shots
and he he lost like big fights that the
next one probably would have been a
title shot and when you lose those in in
MMA there's so many contenders it takes
a long long time to get back to a point
and a lot of people when they lose those
big fights they'll quit but he continued
to push and
he's won like nine ten fights and the
big one everybody talks about was he
fought a guy named a Korean zombie
mm-hmm okay
is that a guy's at a Halloween costume
yeah it's like Boston salmon was another
guy who's fighting this weekend yeah
Boston salmon that's his actual birth
given name Korean Xabi his name's just
like too difficult for people so they
just refer to him everybody just knows
him his Korean Zombie and everybody
thought if Dustin would have won that
fight he would have got a title shot and
and he got knocked out in that one and
it was it was a long road back yeah and
then yeah and um yeah it just like he's
had such a long road to stay on that
road and I guess in some ways I can
relate to it in the sense the same with
comedy because there's something about
it like you know for the first nine
years of doing comedy like you don't
have any stuff on television you know
the internet wasn't even really a run
you know the first six years the
Internet's not even around she was
telling people you're doing it like
basically to think you're an alcoholic
and then it just takes so long and
there's so many moments where you get
off of a stage and you're like man I
remember one time I had a even like my
Netflix special I was like oh this is
the opportunity that's gonna change my
space in the industry and it didn't you
know and it was just like man I thought
that was gonna be it buddy just the
timing wasn't right and I wasn't really
ready I mean in hindsight but at the
time I didn't know that that was your
Korean Zombie
there's my Korean zombie dude and now
I'm eating Boston salmon but I think
that's one thing you get with I think
it's one of the reasons why I love
Maurice Clarett why you know really
respond to him why respond to Dustin's
story you know just seeing him in the
ring at the end and we'll put some
pictures in that there was a moment he's
in the ring and his wife's there behind
him you can just see and I was just on
the edge of the cage and I just just
took as many little pictures as I could
and I was like man this is just such a I
can see it all right here there's just a
moment where you could see just that a
man it works so hard that picture that
you took you know is absolutely epic
like for him like that's like a keepsake
because he he said on our our in your
interview with them this past weekend
number 142 he's like
he's his wife is his middle school
sweetheart she is she used to ride him
to drive him to practice when they had
one car she'd pick him up and he dropped
out in high school so middle school was
it it's not like people are like well
why didn't you get a high school
sweetheart he didn't hang around for all
that right and and you captured it
perfectly he's crying she's in the
background just like looking at it they
did it together it's beautiful yeah yeah
they did it together and when you talk
to him even like even over the past year
you know he and I communicate pretty
decently in he and know and I try to get
more into like learning about the sport
a little bit or seeing what's going on
and his message has always just been I
just want to be the champ man I just
want you know that validation and sure
it's like he only has part of the belt
or whatever they say but that's just the
way it's kind of been unfolding with
people getting suspended people get
busted for this this and that and he
still even though it was an interim belt
he still beat a champion to get the belt
well max is 145 pound champion so I
think that it doesn't lose any anyway
I'd love to see him both fight at 225
the weight yeah see him both from 50
pounds go to Italy for a month it come
back and do it again I forgot to ask him
about about uh about max if he'd talked
to him and guys this isn't turning into
a UFC podcast but look I got to go I've
never been to a fight before you know I
never even been a Wrestlemania you know
I remember I did drink a couple of a guy
sweat one time when I lost a bet one
time but that's like the closest I've
ever been to really till like an event
like that and first of all the first
fight of the night was this guy Brandon
Davis and and that was really it was a
bloodbath I mean these two guys just
stood there and beat a pine out of each
other
I mean it was like Halloween it was like
an episode of JCL I was like it's Jason
Voorhees in this match like there was
just blood everywhere and then it was up
and down from there it was just I don't
know man it was quite a spectacle though
it really blew my mind Shaquille O'Neal
was there I mentioned to you this I
mentioned this to you before but like
the way you described the fight
you're sitting first row you're seeing
your [ __ ] your buddy fight for about
shaquille o'neal's first round it sounds
like a dream someone tells you it just
sounds absurd dude he had a pretzel bro
of an aunt Annies and it was inside of
his entire in the palm of his hand the
whole thing and he just licked it off of
his hand it's like a horse salt like oh
he licked he licked it in half did he
lick it once it was a half of the
pretzel left he bisected it the long way
not like it was it was uh I would
recommend it if you never been to see
something like that I would recommend it
and there was so many great people I met
too many people in the stands and the
weekend started you and I went to
Aerosmith it was awesome what a weekend
I mean we went to Aerosmith and you
didn't did you lose any money how do you
end up yeah I ended up losing even handi
I cut myself off I stayed an extra day
in Vegas cut myself off after after
losing 100 cuz I was up a hundred yeah
initially and then on that extra night I
told you I played in that poker
tournament oh yeah that was those wild
man I played about three hours just to
finish one spot outside the money but it
was one guy almost attacked me after I
beat him with my pocket aces look you
gotta pull that Ridge blade on him yeah
that's right luckily there was a
bodyguard from Floyd Mayweather's the
money team also in the tournament so I
think if [ __ ] went down he would have
had my back also an embezzler probably
from Floyd Mayweather's money he's out
there just getting rid of cash in Vegas
yeah he was a little agitated too
because everything was it was like 12:30
at night and everything around us was
closed and he this guy was like probably
300 pounds and he said he didn't eat
meat so there was like nothing for him
to eat it was it was very bizarre Wow
and the guy who I flipped out on me so
he got out in like the first five hands
that's why I was so pissed and and so
then you can rebuy back into the
tournament yeah and then so after he
flips out he comes he has to sit back at
our table and it was just an incredibly
awkward
that's all Gordon yeah but I outlasted
him again at least that was my goal
after that was my championship
just not lasting that guy yeah and you
said you were one one one spot away from
getting in the money huh yeah and the
hand I went out on had I wanted what I
would have been chip leader at the table
with only six people left uh I would
have been sitting sitting real pretty we
would had a different guy in here today
a guy called my ace nine with an ace
four and he beat me
mmm-hmm well you gave it a shot man yeah
it was super fun it's a way better way
because there's $65 over three hours
that's like you said a blackjack table
that long you could lose way more money
in that so it was fun way to spend the
time or you sit at the Batchelor slot
machine like I did and lose on earn 82
ways to do Vegas guys okay that's two
ways to do yes that was fun though man
in Arrowsmith look for a 71 year old man
that guy had it I thought I thought he
did a great job that was that was
incredible it those guys 70 years old
it's it's insane and the fact that
they're doing that four nights a week -
yeah he's a machine oh we got to tell
you this so they had a so ariseth the
crowd it's a mixed bag there you know is
a lot of first of all it's people know
all the songs you know everybody and the
tickets we had no joke we were seven
feet from the stage probably six feet
from the walk of this walk out part of
the stage and look I've never been that
close to any type of event you know I'm
gonna do usually that's in the back
[ __ ] doing dice with the homeless
didn't I remember being at the Superdome
in New Orleans one time there's a some
guy I think either had schizophrenia was
just lost was at the game banging on the
back wall asking people to let him out
the whole time of the stadium like it's
just like turn around bro nice walk down
you know but I think you just kind of
mixed up or you know I don't know what
the [ __ ] but that dude the whole time
literally knocking on the back wall let
me out
but this was something else man this was
something else we were right up there
and and they had this guy it was a lot
of light probably 40 and 50 year old
couples I would say you know it's not
like it's not a bunch of people smoking
weed and do an acid it
like in in my imagination and then there
was a dude next to has had a couple of
young escorts it seemed like a couple
thoughts with him yeah I think that guy
I think he's just a really big Aerosmith
Aerosmith fan and he wanted to make this
night perfect so yeah he got three of
the prettiest ladies he could find that
some sugar babies and I'm not saying
that they were escorts I don't know that
but they were definitely dates you know
or one of them was his daughter that
also didn't mind touching him a lot so
he had a unique triumvirate of women
with him but it created this weird
energy around us because you had these
other couples that have flown in from
the Midwest or New Jersey or you know or
just driven in from Henderson Nevada and
they were and they were all there to see
her Smith and suddenly there's these
these young bus buxom these young bucks
some ladies milling around right there
and and they were all offended a little
bit you could tell so anyway this man
had these two ladies there these buxom
you know younger ladies and look I get
it you're you know these are older women
and they've you know they spent time
raising their families and stuff like
that they're they're enjoying an era so
maybe they went and saw the band with
their husband when they were young and
now they're in their 50s and they're
back to see the band so then you have
this man right there who obviously has
left his wife and he gots a couple of
thoughts you know a couple of internet
you know choice kind of buxom gals out
there a couple of [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] titty bunnies with him so and
they're right up by the stage and
they're like dancing all over them and
so all of the older men are like ogling
these young ladies and they can't help
it that's nature you know what I'm
saying if you put a [ __ ] if you put
an arm if you put a dime near uh near a
bank the [ __ ] banks gonna look at it
you know and so so Nick anyway I went to
the restroom and Nick take it away Nick
well you know I like to smoke a little
weed now and then yeah
and now they've got all these new
gadgets and gizmos that you
smoke weed out of oh yeah I've got one
of those vape pens that has THC in it
and that's that what it's like an
electric cigarette oh yeah cigarette and
that's for children I thought it was for
teenagers and you have it I do I do but
yeah I don't know my gets you high so I
don't think it's for children oh that's
a good point but but yeah a little
juvenile nonetheless yeah
but either way I was trying to be
respectful of your sobriety not that you
give a [ __ ] or usually have any judgment
but I appreciate it
so you went to the bathroom and I
decided to partake and we had already
your you had already been chatting a
little bit with these these uh these
young ladies yeah one of the girls had
listened to an episode of this past
weekend with a sex worker we'd
interviewed so that right there was just
kind of it was an interesting moment
yeah and she she told you she learned a
lot from it yeah yeah she said oh I've
seen you do comedy before and and and I
start your podcast with the sex worker
so that was pretty that was pretty
it wasn't telling but it was interesting
it very interesting but yeah so when you
went to the bathroom I pulled out my pen
and I hit it to enjoy the concert in
even a different state and look you know
I'm still me like I'm a cop okay I feel
like I'm a police officer
well sir so I got high when you went to
bed and she saw it and she was like oh
is that weed and I was like it is I was
like do you smoke weed cuz cuz it's
strong and she was like she's like yeah
I do I'm fine and she had tits that like
if she said yes her tits would like move
up and down for yes and if she said no
her tits move left and right for no like
it was like she didn't even move her
head her just her tits would move and
they moved up and down for yes so I so I
let her hit it and she was gone
immediately I mean this was like yeah
this was uh it was very much like I'm
trying to relate it to a fight at UFC
that I saw this weekend it was like it
was an immediate knock-down yeah Wilson
haste versa pantoja yeah she she got
knocked out Wilson Hayes yeah yeah it
was it was immediate so next thing you
know nail this lady's sitting in the
chair
and she's like puking into a bag so
suddenly all the Midwest couples and all
the other women are like cheering now
they're all dancing somebody started
singing Jessie's girl Erica thought he
was sing that and you mentioned how a
lot of the older gentlemen were all
distracted by them and all the the women
that were with the older gentlemen they
were appalled at what they were seeing
so then I think you let you were right
they got some satisfaction off seeing
this situation go awry yeah yeah there
was a special moment like in and
suddenly like everybody could have fun
and it was like the aunt last two or
three songs of the concert and it was
like like what it what was supposed to
happen had happened you know the good
the Dark Arts had been defeated okay and
then the guy was like all kind of what
you could tell he was pissed cuz one of
his workers was down you know just
imagine how mad you are if I don't come
into work you know oh definitely yeah
and I had to turn the cameras on myself
Jesus out of [ __ ] lost my mind I had
to put that in there but mr. officer I
will say that that was just a weed pen
and she had to have been drunk pretty
drunk before to have that effect on her
dude it was so funny because literally
she goes from being this pair of tits
that even Steven Tyler would come over
like he had somebody else sing a song at
one point and he's just over like
looking at this girl's tats and then
finally um and then finally justice was
served Nick hit her with that weed and
put her out oh dude this is a [ __ ]
mental calligraphy this [ __ ] she was
that was it and then I don't know if you
remember I thought you you made Steven
Tyler walk off stage at one point
because their last song of their setlist
was was dude looks like a lady mm-hmm
and then they go yeah yeah he was
holding the mic out to like different
parts of the crowd and when he got to
our section you were looking down at
your phone and he wanted us all to
respond and you didn't and then the
concert game ended almost immediately
after I thought you pissed him off but
it turns out that's the regular setlist
now I remember that dude and I [ __ ]
felt horrible it was like and I'd paid
attention is probably 92% of the concert
you know I caught what I could on my
phone some people were it was too much
on the phone like those the thoughts and
even that old guy who hired the thoughts
dude you know they were on there they
were just video recording the whole time
but I try to embrace it in that one
moment he came and you saw me looked at
me huh yeah yeah I was yeah yeah I was
[ __ ] right there dude and I looked at
him the whole time hoping you'd look at
and the one moment he looks Mike was
maybe 18 inches from now would I was
gonna sing the wrong song I'm glad maybe
I wasn't I was because if I'd have just
turned around and was like Jesse's girl
I could have ruined it mm-hmm oh but man
what a time and to go from one close
range thing where people are singing one
and where people are fighting I'd way
rather be a singer a hundred percent you
gotta hit a high note instead of hit
another [ __ ] easily do during
the fight man oh god it was just so
intense man and you're right there in
Joe Rogan seats I'm gonna put a little
video up on patreon of what Joe Rogan
seats are like and uh and you just you
know you're right there and there's
cameras production going on so you kind
of want to be cognizant of that and
there's people there's some guy yelling
Rat King the whole time but there was a
lot of great people in the stands you
got to me to go you know just it was
well Friday night I did sorry Friday
night I did Joe sho did a surprise spot
on Joe's show in Atlanta and I'm gonna
apologize for anybody that saw that that
was uh that was so I come out cold right
it was cold audience so I walk out the
lights are still on it wasn't like a
convention center wasn't in like a
typical place where you would do a
comedy show so I walk out and it's like
Jesus Christmas man bah like I have no
clue how to open a show anymore I lost
that I'm used to going at the end you
know I'm used to the comfortable spot I
might used to having asleep in you know
on the floor he's just sleeping up
the bed you know when it's cozy and and
it was a humbling experience man
Oh at one point I didn't even know what
my joke was I was in the middle of a bit
and I just screamed I was like fry one
point I tied my shoe that's how well it
was going oh this is going so good take
a break tighten up the outfit man that
was hectic too but afterwards I get off
stage Joe's like I'm definitely paying
you for that one that's what he said
so I knew that it wasn't really super
great but we had a blast him and then we
went out to eat afterwards and and you
know Joe Rogan he's drinking he got all
kind of special things he pulled out of
it that man sack you pull a little
couple pints of [ __ ] uh you know
hummingbird [ __ ] spit you know you
know drink that on the spot he'll
Dripping into his eyeballs you know what
I'm saying you know Joe Rogan he's doing
wild stuff he'll pull a couple of
[ __ ] little you know he had a little
bag and it was part of it was froat had
it froze he had a freezer section in his
fanny pack
he had [ __ ] a little cheetah legs in
their little uh cheetah drumettes just
eaten the [ __ ] the short arms of
cheetah just [ __ ] nibbling on them
you know dipping him in ranch real ranch
like a section of land from Montana just
dipping it right into it you know like
he had French dressing doubt and it was
real I think it was just the blood of
Napoleon Bonaparte and he just [ __ ]
basking in that and him [ __ ] have a
little bit of that cheetah leg he was
drinking all kind I mean yeah when you
were Joe Rogan you don't know what he's
having
you know he's taking he's on all the dog
he's got all the wildest supplements you
know at one point I heard a falcon
[ __ ] vomited it like just in into the
air thousands of feet away and Rogan
[ __ ] caught her in his pocket you
know use that for later in case he you
know to a special south to solve a
situation and then at one point he got a
call no joke on his phone bro it said
Neptune I was like Jesus Christ huh they
must have been Eddie Bravo huh
that must have well it didn't say flat
Neptune then it would have been but I
was like but his ringtone was their
actual
of Saturn and I was like this is too
much and it's sometimes when you're
hanging out you're Rogen it's just uh I
mean it's a history lesson it's a
geology lesson it's a philosophy lesson
I mean who you never know what's gonna
go on you know I mean the bread the
bread basket at dinner with him tasted
like Sokrates bro like [ __ ] so crazy
boy unbelievable but anyway man I
[ __ ] bomb so if you if you want to
know what it's like here's here's what I
think it would be like go to your first
job and have to do it right now what
would that be for you knew I'd be
working at the library which is where
you're gonna be working at these [ __ ]
cameras don't get [ __ ] tightened up
anyway I had to throw that in um you be
working at the library yeah do you think
you could handle it now the library
would you lose your mind I lose my mind
for sure I wasn't a good employee back
then so really yeah man I because my job
was magazines and the periodicals oh
yeah yeah so I just spent a lot of my
time flipping through magazines not as
beautiful it's where I got a lot of uses
in formation I guess so dude dude I
remember I go into the library man the
library was like a place where you know
the lights were on
you could be in there they weren't gonna
kick you out really because there was
just the library you just had to be
quiet and if you weren't quiet that it's
told you to be quiet every five minutes
all day and you could still be there and
I remember I go once I started reading
but you know regular books as a child
and then because my mom instead of
getting us a babysitter soon was just
tickets to the library and it should be
the library four or five hours you know
and they have free water they have water
fountains bathrooms were nice you know
and they had they had microfiche and
stuff like that you should be able to
rent a movie at the library even but I
remember I once I started getting
erections and getting into sex and stuff
like that are thinking about it they I'd
go look at those rubenesque women and
then like though the rubenesque art
period you know in those books and they
had naked women in the books I mean
people had drawn them and I remember get
I would close my erection in the book
until I [ __ ]
kein like real real hard you know and
then I'd feel so [ __ ] bad about
myself and so bad about art so I'm glad
I'm not doing that kind of [ __ ] anymore
but oh but anyway what I say I would
talk last feed about masturbation I you
know I'd done like a hundred and maybe
ten days of not of no masturbation but a
pornography there's a great there's a
call relating to this oh really yeah I
think if you look at the sheets like
number five or six okay maybe two let's
uh god I feel looking at porn yeah okay
let's listen out right now right do
Straker from Kansas City what's up Jacob
thank you for calling brother me and my
buddy that you called big white who saw
you at the late Friday show in Casey oh
yeah dude that's [ __ ] big whitey
white bra big [ __ ] marshmallow
[ __ ] Johnson um you know last week
you talked about masturbation in the
dark arts man and you know when we
talked I thank you for the crusade
against the dark art of masturbation oh
yeah self coming go on and what really
shouldn't look is when you said that you
looked at the pornography on Saturday
night or Sunday night after the show and
I was like [ __ ] because when I talked to
you you said it was going to get you
thinking about it and you know all that
[ __ ] so [ __ ] man hope I didn't make you
masturbate but if I did stay strong you
know do a lot for people more than you
know well for you apparently out us
masturbate brother so I don't think you
did man I mean I don't know if you put
it in my head I think what happens for
me is if I haven't slept much and that's
what happened I hadn't slept much and I
got just kind of frustrated and you know
I've been taking good care of myself and
I wanted to do something I wanted to
[ __ ] throw a javelin out of a [ __ ]
window off of a building and [ __ ] hit
somebody at a bus stop or I wanted to
you know tie Christmas wreaths around
some greedy [ __ ] neck and then just
hook it to it you know hook it to a you
know to a car and just drag that bastard
around town playing
and Christmas carols on the jukebox in
the car you know I just wanted to do
some type of violence I wanted to act
out you don't wanted to take one of my
[ __ ] arms and just beat somebody with
it literally take it off my body I
wouldn't be awesome you could take your
left arm off your body
put your then rip it off your body right
then with your right arm with your right
hand you grab your left hand and now you
have a super long arm
let us bones sticking out of the end and
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of
people with it sorry look that's what
happened you go to UFC man you come back
do you think about that kind of stuff
but I wanted to act out so I hope it
wasn't because of you and big whitey
that I [ __ ] ended up doing
masturbation man you know I really hope
it wasn't but yeah I watched a
pornography and I felt horrible about it
you know I got caught up in it and you
know it even got deeper for me man I uh
you know I started I thought I thought
about getting escorts and Las Vegas and
you know and and it even took me in a
kind of like a dark place there where
you know I was really you know and even
kind of looked into it you know to be
honest I didn't even just think about it
you know I and it didn't end up
happening so I'm thankful that that's
the way that it worked out but yeah it's
like one thing I don't know if one thing
leads to the next but one thing doesn't
help the next you know but yeah man I
mean I'm not really proud to say it but
because I've been doing real good with
that kind of stuff but you know I had uh
yeah looked into getting an escort and
then you know and I had even had it kind
of lined up and then uh you know she
said that she wasn't feeling good and I
was like well I don't want to sick you
know prostitute that's a bad idea
you know I'm saying I wouldn't I
wouldn't try to do any kind of sexual
activity with anybody when they're sick
you know even if somebody sneeze and I'm
gonna try to [ __ ] them I mean Annette's
I've always said that you know but so
anyway I'm just kind of grateful to do
it that it worked out the way it
because it left me with a little bit
more integrity and I thought anything's
wrong with it it's just I didn't really
want to be doing that I don't think it's
wrong with something with hire and women
that are sex workers or anything like
that but I just didn't want to be doing
it and I just knew that I didn't want to
be doing it and uh and so I'm kind of
glad it worked out the way that it did
and I don't know if I would have gone
through it there but I planned on it you
know I planned on you know just I've
really just kind of given into the dark
arts really uh but then some other stuff
happened that day that kind of were just
like real like life kind of things like
one of my friend's dad's passed away and
and it kind of brought me back into like
a more of a reality space and so I was
glad I hadn't heard from this lady I
didn't hear anything from her and then
and I hadn't reached out and then
finally I got a message says hey I'm not
feeling well and so I was really
grateful I'm just grateful that somebody
there was a there's a power out there
that had a bigger plan than I did for
myself so anyway that's a short
turnaround to you uh you had a flight
out at 7 a.m. and we finished you in
like 12:30
yeah and now was the dark arts man and
instead I got to go eat women tea you
know cuz that's when I probably try to
meet up with her with a escort at night
you know I'm not [ __ ] somebody for
money in the daytime you know what I'm
saying that's you know the saint
Morocco or something and I don't know
what that means let's get into a couple
of the calls here that came in oh man
what a day huh there is one news story
on there that was related to pornography
well let's get into it man yeah man I
guess do the saddest thing about it I
only want to talk about it that much
maybe I'll talk about it more next week
there's a new story about pornography
yeah and it says right here a Michigan
man is seeking more than 86,000 from his
parents in civil court for allegedly
throwing out his large pornography
collection the man moved back into his
parents home after a divorce a year
later the man moved and
when his parents discovered his property
the parents delivered his property to
his new home the porn was missing he
tried to press charges look that's a
collection at a certain point you can't
get that quality art anymore it's all
video now there's no art to it there
used to be the artistic edge of seeing
two people [ __ ] a magazine you didn't
know you know there's maybe a little bit
of backstory you know Janet you know
Janet used to work at a at a Deutsche
Bank or something you know there used to
be something you know Kaleb was a you
know rides horses and you get a little
more information so you had on the page
you almost got to know him each page was
a little bit more in the beginning there
was like a bale of hay and some titties
and somebody had a hat on and then by
the end people were just doing sex and
for that man to lose all of this in one
fell swoop that's pretty heavy it's
pretty heavy man but also his parents
are really battling the da's man they're
battling the dark arts by throwing that
out my throne and in the incinerator the
dad he had a quote it seemed like he was
really had his sons best interests at
heart the father told the son believe it
or not the one reason for why I
destroyed your porn was for your own
mental and emotional health I would have
done the same if I had found a kilo of
crack cocaine someday I hope you will
understand you came [ __ ] throw Kent
cocaine out like that you know I'm
saying put it in a special place don't
pitch it you know you got to put that in
a dam in a cocaine Museum or something
how is there not a crack museum another
great idea oh wow look at that eight
look at the hall hall day eight ball
that's it would be called must be all
eight balls from around the world and
the Liberty Bell yeah yeah the Liberty
Bell has crack if it is cracked yeah
gang good choice oh man here we are man
let's do this right here let's say we
got some other calls that came in about
the UFC fights the oh man here we go
we're here Lana was that
UFC fights last night if you can't tell
by the a [ __ ] throat problem I got
right now
oh yeah man I feel you and look dude my
head hurts so bad after the Kevin Kelvin
Gastelum fight which I wanted him to win
so bad dude he's built just like kind of
like I don't even know what he's built
like he's built like some guy at the
beach that you know definitely is gonna
drink all day I mean he felt like he was
wearing board shorts he was the only
fighter wearing no joke swim trunks
during the fight okay like if he would
have walked over his corner and cracked
open a bush light would not have been
shocked and he I thought he was gonna
get I thought he's gonna beat his Rea
Israel but dude I wouldn't buy that last
fight my head hurt so bad I could barely
even cheer man and that's the one I was
there for the most let's hear more
they're watching you during that Poirier
fight was just as in the Testament we
lost the suit in the first round I did
lose my [ __ ] in the first round and
that's when they said you got to gotta
calm down
nobody said if I could feel everybody
about to say it you know even the Rat
King guy who'd been yelling racking the
whole time was like so that's when I
knew I did tight I had to turn it down a
notch let's hear more
I'm glad Rogan got you in there man got
to see see the best sport out there man
I tell you feeling it glide see you had
a good time man glad your boy brought
home this traffic strap keep doing the
damn thing man killing it appreciate it
love you Gang Gang man love you too
brother thanks for a thank for for the
call yeah I'm glad I look hot dude I was
up out of my seat I was losing my mind I
even got a tech from Brennan child and
he said hey man I can hear you in the
background of the fights get your [ __ ]
together I could hear you at times do so
crazy I don't even always yelling I was
yelling dangerous stuff damn I hit him
in the neck I yelled one time and that's
when somebody I think even Shaquille
O'Neal looked at me and he'd been hacked
he knew that's that hack-a-shaq he
probably heard that before
foul him
make him shoot free-throws I yelled out
one time during one of the fights so you
could tell sometime I didn't know what
was happening we got another call here
the hotline as always is nine eight five
six two six six six four nine five zero
three it's ninety five six six four nine
five zero three can't believe I forgot
that I discombobulated yeah yeah well
it's just because the first forty
minutes of this episode are gonna have
to be in drawing form but cuz the
cameras aren't on but it's gonna be
interesting but hey we made it through
it right I think it's great episode
still that's fire well at least we have
at least we look I'm glad that we
persevered it's one thing we learned
from Dustin Poirier man you know we
could have fallen out we could have
stopped it we could have got furious
these cameras are my Korean Zombie
yeah these your Korean Zombie dude and
one of them you said was on but I'm
really curious to see how you montage
clips from other episodes to make it
look like I'm talking all these things
so it'll be interesting let's hear this
at this a call came in all right here's
my audition for a dragon great block
pizza it's the best pizza in California
it's got some sausages and hot peppers
and it's so glued it blew my sister's
legs off but we still order pizzas to go
great block pizza at the hospital threes
are so good great block pizza right by
the beach for a block pizza it's good
it's good like that man I'll tell you
this the way to a girl's heart brah
it ain't through her legs anymore it's
through her [ __ ] stomach I think that
could be kind of fun if every once a
while we few people send in their reads
for gray-black pizza and we play em I
like that so yeah we'll do that for the
next couple of episodes if you want to
submit a read for gray block pizza then
summit the aviary ad read at nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
oh man
yeah what a weekend bro what a weekend
and I never go do anything fun you know
always just do work so when I'm home you
got us like to relax you know I like to
watch a little bit of Dateline see if
anybody got you know going through some
tough times I mean I can't even sleep
without a murder sometimes you know and
that's the dark arts that's when you
know you're getting infected so I got to
start watching some other stuff and you
know just being more open to some new
ideas what else not much I'm on a West
Palm Beach in a couple of weeks you can
get those tickets at theof on comm slash
tour that's April 27th and 28th what
else Nick man I can't believe you
freaking down that thought boy you down
that busty bunny boy you put he doped up
that what was in that dope man just a
lot of dope bro I mean that [ __ ] she
looked like who's something that was up
you gave her that Boston salmon brother
she hug can hit them Izzy she hit the
mad bro
like literally I come back and then the
guys other girl came over you know with
the little you know he came over and
said hey would you get my girl
just a little THC little THC dude
and she was that she was out unless he
was she fights next and I knew max all
the way let's take another call here we
go I feel this is Sarah calling from
Michigan long short time listener person
caller thanks for calling Sarah from
Michigan let's hear more and I'm in my
late 20s and decided to be celibate I
had a lot of sexual relations in my 20s
and not really finding it very sizzling
anymore and what do we tell I need
someone that I really connect with and
have
decent relationship with so I was hoping
that you could give me some advice
regarding when to tell someone that I'm
not going to be an easy conquest when is
the best time that I told someone that
well right now you just told them and uh
but that's a good question when do you
tell somebody that I think you know I
think you could let them know them at
the end of the first date in an
appropriate way you can let them know in
the beginning I've asked women out and
they said from the beginning if you're
just looking for sex or sexual interest
or touching or something like that or
body touching then I'm not that person
don't come around here with that you
know I got a kid or I got you know a
couple cats or whatever and my trying to
put them through that some lady didn't
want a man in fewer cats until like the
fifth date I was like I don't give a
[ __ ] I was like I don't want to meet him
even if it's 200 dates I don't want to
[ __ ] meet them cats you know some
lady said why don't you come by the
house you know case [ __ ] mittens
and bunny first of all you named a cat
Barney oh that's pretty nuts who would
name a cat Bonnie and what are you
supposed to do Easter he's just losing
his [ __ ] and doesn't know why he thinks
it's his fault that once a year he
[ __ ] this losers loses his [ __ ]
mind and starts writing cadbury in his
in his litter box with his arm huh hurry
[ __ ] why does that cat on the
internet that does the computer the
office space one then the cat that works
at Xerox or whatever what the [ __ ] is
going on I don't ever want to meet your
cat's lady and you can tell him that
I'll write him a damn note dude I'll
[ __ ] write a little note on the back
of a piece of salmon a nothing you give
him that he ain't coming I ain't
bringing I ain't bringing him out of
house until you know she said yeah
meeting my Castille the fifth date
and you know what I do if you ever do
bring me over there to meet him I'm a
hot milk in my shoes and make them lose
their [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] hot some 4% then
bottom each of my boots and just just be
that [ __ ] lean that leche snapper and
have this little [ __ ] losing
their minds so I don't want to even date
that you know I don't be no cat step
daddy lady
so get your mind right but anyway were
we talking about Sarah
yeah celibacy it's uh I mean you know
what they say this [ __ ] ain't for
everybody that's what they say usually
when people are celibate and they say
you know uh you must respect this house
and that's actually I think part of a
underarm rad underarmour ad but still
it's similar in that sense you mom
you know you must respect this house you
feel me this vajazzle you know what I'm
saying
the drawbridge is up on this vajazzle
and that's what you're saying and I
think you let a guy know that in the
beginning just say if you're looking for
so if you're not looking for something
serious but don't bait him with it the
whole time either don't draw a little
bitter you know don't draw a little you
know leave a little pubic hairs on a
napkin
you know don't leave a little pippick
hairs on this plate after he's done
eating so he you know he goes to the
bathroom after dinner he comes back and
then got some freakin public hairs on
the edge of his plate he's gonna be like
what's it worth don't don't trick him
like that you know just tell him
straight up and don't hold it over his
head oh and maybe next I'm gonna do all
of that [ __ ] you know don't do you know
it's not a bartering tool you know it's
a but it is it's your item you know and
maybe he don't want to share the wiener
a lot of these ladies thinking oh I'm
keeping the kitty at they you know at
the corral you know I'm keeping the
carpet the at the UH in the cauldron
but what if sometimes yeah oh man don't
want to share the Wiener with you ladies
sometimes I ain't [ __ ] sharing the
Wiener
I'll tell you the look wieners out you
know uh out of order I'll hang a dang
son I'll tie a little you know I'll put
a little I'll tie a little man I'll
shave a message into my public area uh
go on fishing that's what I'll write
because sometime you're Manning the
wieners aren't always available so don't
act like it's always read it's always
out there for you I think everybody
could say look it's no dick August you
know what I'm saying that's what I'm
doing ladies who's ready for no dick
August these ladies thinking they keep
getting this Wiener whenever they want
think again walking in a winter
wonderland no you're not
you better moonwalk you ass on out of
here because you he's lost you use
having a damn lunar eclipse if you think
he's getting this wiener anytime any day
this ain't that 7-eleven a dick booboo
okay this this is this dick got limited
hours okay this the Chase Bank a dick
and you better this is only during
certain hours and also I'm only working
sometime with private clients so that's
what I'm saying this Weiner and
available forever what were we talking
about
but if you're trying to be celibate look
I think you tell them up top what do you
think Nick yeah I agree
that's good way to weed them out yeah
yeah man I can't stop thinking about the
fact that I almost got that escort I
think it's interesting though that like
because you've been sober now over
two-and-a-half years and like people
listening may think okay he's better now
like he's not struggling anymore but
it's like these things can still spring
up like even when everything is like
going well you just get these urges yeah
yeah it's funny because I didn't uh you
know I had no thoughts about it and then
I think is just you know I don't know
what it was what what it was was I
wanted to do what I wanted to do you
know I didn't want to I didn't want to
you know I wanted to do something that I
wasn't supposed to do I guess and it's
also my own walls if I put up if I don't
want to do that but yeah I just I don't
know man
so I'm grateful that you know I mean I
know it's it's easy to say well I'm
happy they got you know that my higher
power didn't you know kind of let the
things fold out the way that they were
that I had planned but you know I I mean
I felt like I kind of got cold feet
about it or cold dick I guess they
called it and um and I'm thankful that I
that you know a higher power could do do
for me what I couldn't do for myself
really you know but yeah I just think
looking at that pornography just spurned
me it spurned me it's like when somebody
drives by your house and [ __ ] you
know she you know somebody takes a
bullet full of creme brulee into shoots
that [ __ ] right in your throat from
sixty yards away you're like God that
was good but now your brains thing in
the desert and before I really had had
good control over my brain but I've been
so busy recently I hadn't really been
focusing on a lot of just the things I
need to do to keep myself in a good
place and and I'm not being hard on
myself I don't think you know I just
want to I just want to be making
decisions that I definitely want to make
you know so I guess part of me is just
like is that something I wanted to do or
is that something I felt like I was
doing because I was being deviant you
know I think that's the sugar lizards
sibling the [ __ ] lizard well the sugar
listen go for anything oh okay then it's
the sugar lizard yeah I don't have to
say the p-word in here gotcha I mean we
say once an episode maybe but we won't
say it flat out like that with both
asses
you know I'm sorry am I trying to be
rude or anything but I should have known
better
how else could you say it you think me
yeah Wasi was there you go one that why
my dangerous son Oh
but good luck out there Sara being
celibate and you do whatever you want to
do shut it down dude seal that thing up
don't eat your vagina to charity or
whatever you know mail that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] vag gana Stan do whatever you
want to do with it I mean I think
[ __ ] is getting outdated anyway this
some people still [ __ ] maybe in areas
but a lot of people aren't a lot of
people are over it there's bigger fish
to fry out there you know those Boston
salmon yeah there's Boston salmon yo
what's up there this man out of LA
originally Indianapolis see that you're
going down to Australia next month and
I'm so excited man ASA did this little
bitty down there she explained recently
but good memories of that oh yeah that's
that hemisphere crotch when you jump in
hemisphere to catch some legs on this
you know that ain't that local I need
that Boston salmon today who I got
caught in from Twitter
you know black hole just got sucked down
some odd zeros football highlights oh I
know what it was I was looking up like
how to spell yeah oh well they had only
how to spell yeah yeah look it up in
yellow means cocaine know Google's like
did you mean go yeag turns out he's a
solid rules football player just start
watching his highlight reel they get on
Twitter she slows things um but when
you're down there man that was one thing
I can do I highly recommend it then I'm
Sean Payton down there but then I'm
trying to cute or clever it's just it's
like American football and rugby you
know all mixed into one
you know I'd love to see some of it
actually had a man hit me up on Dam and
he's a player down there one of the
teams and I'll look and see who he is
and he invited me to a match over in
Perth during the afternoon which I think
I'll actually be able to attend so it
could be pretty cool but thank you for
the recommendation at Aussie Rules
Football
and uh yeah I'd like to try it you know
I'm excited about being down there and
I'm gonna try to take a vacation the
week before that and go somewhere I
really need to decide today but man this
weekend was fun it was just so much fun
to like just do stuff that I just didn't
have to work you know even though I did
jump on Joe Rogan show and take a
[ __ ] L bro God dude I've taken an
elbow before and this was an L bro I
took that [ __ ] son but it was good man
it's exactly what I needed you know it
was nice to just just to feel that
humility
you know like man this is what this is
what it's like when everything is not
you know you know when you got to go
first when you you know you're out of
your comfort zone you and Nate bargatze
kind of talked about something similar
how now every time you perform like
people are excited they're ready to see
you they're ready to laugh but this was
kind of that thing where you got to get
him on your side first
since you're opening the show and yeah
yeah yeah you got to get him on your
side first and I did I went I went out
and I'll kind of win in a material then
I wasn't going I didn't know what to do
I got scared it was honestly man it was
pretty cool cuz then I still had to stay
in there I still had to stay it's like
[ __ ] finally made it through some moment
this rounds over people were coming in
somebody was drunk you know people were
yelling stuff and it was like it [ __ ] it
was set up for like a TED talk you know
it wasn't even there was no backstage
like backstage it was just like a wall
and it was so we're like just standing
there right behind the curtain usually
there's like a place to chill out and
stuff it was a wild man but but I'm just
grateful I guess I'm just I don't know I
went through it and Here I am and that's
life take another call here yeah what's
up video this is Jake down :
I'm just wanted to let you know this
past weekend I hit three weeks of
sobriety and Gang Gang baby that's
awesome man congratulations Jake I'm
calling you from a rehab center right
now but yeah man things are going good
I'm hitting three
1/2 weeks now and getting getting better
getting getting healthy and I just want
to thank you for what you do and I also
want to thank my boy Kai for giving me
this number while I was in here and he's
been following a podcast for a minute
now gang man looks nicer that's sweet
that he shared that you know what you
see any just yeah and others more the
call yeah yeah ok that's sweet that he
shared that that castrator with y'all
word but when he showed it to me I
thought you know I'm gonna give this guy
a call and see what's up but yeah man
I'm going through some some serious
stuff right now I've got four weeks here
at rehab going down the first week was
detox another pain in the ass oh but
making the best of it I'm finding I'm
finding out who my real self is and
you've been a huge inspiration to me so
thank you for that it's going to get off
of that blow cane and that sweet sweet
green you know but um thank you again
dude I appreciate everything you do man
alright peace gang man I just liked
apart how he said he's getting to know
his true self now that like the cloud of
the drugs are gone like yeah you talked
a lot about to when you get off that
stuff you start feeling feelings and I
feel like that's what he's going through
at the moment yeah yeah I appreciate you
making sure that I played all of that
Nick um man I appreciate that I did it
so sweetie to call and just share that
that's the realest thing you know it's
like yeah just you're right back there
someone's like you're like an infant
like with feelings again it's like
feelings become like these new toys that
you're just not used to you don't know
how to play with you no matter behave
around and uh and and you stay sober so
then everyday it's like you're playing
with them the most purest way you can
you know you showing up each day to to
hold yourself accountable and to [ __ ]
these are my feelings and these things
are raw as [ __ ] you know because at some
point in my life I chose
to cover them up you know to cover up
these things so I wouldn't feel them you
just layer stuff over them and so it can
be anything and you know or you know it
could be used drugs it could be food it
could be anger it could be sex it could
be anything that we use to cover up
whatever those these like seeds of
discomfort are and I just think it's
courageous man I think it's I think you
know I hope you stay sober for as long
as you want to and I and and if you
don't and that's fine none that there's
no right or wrong way to do it only you
know if you have a problem with
addiction but I think it's brave you
know I think it's brave to meet life
head-on you know there's times this
weekend man I was at the fight and
people are having a beer there's times I
you know went out with Joe rogon's and
he's eating [ __ ] you know Dalmatian
nuggets or whatever he's snacking on and
uh and and I'm wondering and they're
having a whiskey him and whiskey ginger
[ __ ] Andrew Santa Barra
that guy's a dancer the [ __ ] ginger
that whatever a camera's name is [ __ ]
ginger AIDS he said that they're having
a whiskey and it's night time and ever
and I wanted to have one but I wanted to
stay in my line a little you know and I
wanted to just I don't know man and it's
not wrong what they did it's not right
what I did it's just it gives me
something to do every day to wake up in
battle you know see what these feelings
are inside of me and I and I applaud you
for doing that for just trying it and
and if people aren't doing it that
everybody's different some people don't
have to deal with their feelings like
like I do you know when I wake up in the
morning my feelings are right there and
they're ready to [ __ ] with me dawg you
know when they want to [ __ ] with me
and they want to they want to ruin my
day a lot of times they want me they
just need to be babysat they're all
these babies it's like it's like this
baby inside of me it's like I just it's
not taken care of and I got to take care
of it so I got a I got to manage well
and I can't do that if I'm using
drugs and alcohol right now maybe one
day I'll be able to but I applaud you
man I didn't mean to go off on that
tangent but yeah I don't know I guess
just a lot going on and that's good
that's life and here we are I think we
might wrap up for today you know it's
been a long episode you know we've been
through some you know we've been through
some moments we didn't know about there
were coming we persevered
you know we stayed in it you know it's
that I think it's that Dustin Poirier
technique you know we just you just stay
in it you know and we don't be too hard
on ourselves Jake it will be too hard on
yourself down and rehab you know you
went through detox and you're doing it
you're doing it and it's it's your
journey man you're doing it you know
what he got the girl trying to shut down
the vagina you know the hurva Jimmy
John's they're closing early you know no
free smells over here they shutting down
and people are making choices you know
I'm choosing to you know trying to get
back off the pornography so now I got I
think maybe four days three days and I'm
back you know I'm back
that's the beauty of each day you kind
of get a chance to start new each time
ah but but I'm just I'm happy to be back
here with you with you guys in the
studio and you know appreciate you Nick
for being here with me today you know
like I know it you know it wasn't easy
and I'm sorry if I was rude if I didn't
handle myself super well you handle
yourself fine I'm not feeling great
about the mistake but it's all we can do
is move on man and it's all we can do
man and everything's working out the way
it's supposed to everything's gonna be
okay and I say that to myself really
okay sometimes I need to hear it
but yeah man such a fun weekend I would
recommend anybody go to UFC fight I
recommend anybody go see Aerosmith what
do you think Nick oh yeah if you do both
one night
oh my go to heaven I go directly to
heaven dude do not pass Sara's house do
not collect any vagine you know cuz
ain't serving it over there anymore
alright you guys be good to yourselves
man you deserve it I know that and I
hope you do we'll leave out actually the
same way we came in with this man
Jameson flood every night
[Music]
[Applause]
every night by Jameson flood
[Music]
[Applause]
we made it
[Music]
you